josée legault paul wells michel david
bonsoir bonsoir
je vais vous faire entendre un monsieur
bertholle députés conservateurs qui
l'ancien appelle aujourd'hui aux
manifestants de rentrer à la maison je
saigne qui dénonce l'inaction du
gouvernement trudeau et monsieur
blanchet qui dit le invités nous faut
qu'on en parle faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose ça ne se peut pas on écoute et on
revient à ces manifestants ici ottawa
vous êtes venu apporter un message
le message a été entendu
les conservateurs vous ont entendu et
nous vous défendront ainsi que tous les
canadiens qui veulent reprendre la vie
telle que nous la connaissions
et madame la présidente soyez assurés
que nous n'arrêterons pas tant que les
confinements et les obligations
vaccinales ne seront pas terminés
et c'est aussi et l'excès table que le
premier ministre du pays du g7 un des
pays les plus puissantes au monde n'agit
pas ne montre pas de leadership régler
cette situation est particulièrement
c'est complètement inacceptable qu'un
frontier le plus important du amérique
du nord est fermé à ce moment à windsor
abbas leur pont lieu de possibles
développements extrêmement troublant à
ottawa et ailleurs à travers le canada
présentement est ce que le premier
ministre était convoqué les chefs de
partis à une rencontre d'urgence je suis
en contact étroit avec des partenaires
aux différents paliers de gouvernement
les conversations avec d'autres
parlementaires et je suis très content
d'offrir à au chef du bloc 1 breffages
pas pour qu'ils soient mises au jour
onu ue y aura dans quelques heures une
rencontre en effet changer la gauche je
pense que j'avais pu entendre pablo
rodriguez est en fait il dit c'est la
police d'ottawa pour ottawa la grc ou à
la police de windsor pour le pont dans
l'impression l'acquisition et puis ça
baisse et c'est l'impression que
plusieurs canadiens ont depuis hier fait
depuis deux semaines parce que ça fait
deux semaines que ça dure à ottawa on a
aussi maintenant le blocage qui coûte
extrêmement cher qui ternit aussi la
réputation du canada
on a aussi les convois les petits clones
là qui ont poussé à québec il ya
l'équipe hausse en europe partout alors
c'est une action aulas sur le plan
politique va commencer a coûté au
gouvernement libéral s'il n'y a pas
quelque chose de fait je comprends
l'argument de monsieur rodrigue est ce
que c'est pour gouvernement fédéral à
tes larmes il faudrait que ce soit dans
le poêlon demande mais il ya peut-être
d'autres solutions avant la remise on
peut peut-être en parler il y en a sept
certains mais là il ya plus politique
qui va se payer mais l'important pour le
moment c'est que les résidents d'ottawa
sont soumis à sa calvaire là depuis deux
semaines et ça ne se termine pas on perd
énormément d'argent aussi l'économie
perd d'argent et on a convoi les
organisateurs qui va juste une chose
déstabiliser la démocratie et l'économie
canadienne alors c'est très sérieux pour
l'heure je ne l'est vraiment cette
impression que le gouvernement est
paralysé que ça savent pas par quel bout
prendre ça que oui c'est un problème
policiers oui mais y'a pas qu'un
problème policiers il pourrait avoir un
autre plan fait qu'en pensez vous
on a le sentiment d'assister à
l'impuissance généralisée on ne voit
presque plus le premier ministre depuis
plusieurs jours aujourd'hui c'était une
question de 45 minutes
d'engueulades de période des questions
mais sinon il n'a eu aucun événement
public aujourd'hui et c'est
grosso modo comme ça avec lui depuis
plusieurs jours il ay n'arrive le
federer a du mal à se concerter avec les
autres paliers du gouvernement
les sources fédérales que j'ai sont à
peine abordées par le refus de dog fort
de la part de dartford 2 2
se réunir avec le fédéral et la ville
d'ottawa sur ce dossier là à 3 qui est
quand même une ville ontarienne ouais et
on voit en adoptant quelques semaines
lorsque des cinq années à céder aux
camionneurs accès accéléré
le calendrier du déconfinement pour la
data ça ça n'a eu aucune faire ça une
ambition tagore
effectivement surtemps correa coûte mais
paul juste avant d'arriver à vous
monsieur
le premier ministre l'ontario est ce que
c'est parce que parce qu'il ya une
raison le sport passe qui est malade il
n'y a pas de télé c'est ce qui se passe
est ce que c'est parce qu'il ne la peur
d'être perçus comme états
contre cette mouvance là et dans le fion
public assez large de gens qui disent on
n'en peut plus des mesures certains est
ce que c'est pour ceux qui restent
cachés
d'oxford serein l'allié naturel des
camionneurs
c'est un brave type dut banlieue
même si millionnaire il donne
l'impression d'être
classe travailleurs et ses électeurs
sont beaucoup plus sympathique avec les
camionneurs c'est ce que les électeurs
des libéraux fédéraux et pourtant il est
le site
déjà se parait il il est insulté par les
camionneurs au même titre que justin
trudeau et on a l'impression que
d'autres fois pour lequel être mais est
très important est un peu paralysés par
cette situation non oui michel david oui
il m'arrive de me demander ce que
monsieur trudeau père avaient refait
dans un seul sens comme celle-là je
pense que si vous voyez ça comme quand
on regarde tout ça hier a dit ce sont
des pleutres comme et camier v10 de
brian mulroney à l'époque de meech jeu
probable d'imaginer qu'au bout de dix
jours monsieur trudeau pain sera encore
rentré de
de son monde et son monde de renvoyer la
balle d'abord puis de l'autre il ya
quelque chose le kiki totalement
surréaliste josé le disais tantôt le
canada c'est quand même pas une ride en
principe heures je ne vois pas beaucoup
de pays au monde qui pourrait tolérer
que ça dure comme ça puis en fin de
semaine on ne pourrait même presque un
parc belmont lol ils vont arriver avec
des jeux gonflables ça devient
pratiquement ridicule
je connais pas la façon de sortir de là
mais écoutez il va falloir et
éventuellement puis je pense que ça va
passer par une manifestation de force je
vois je vois pas du tout comment ça peut
se négocier parce que qu'est-ce qui a
négocié négocier la survie des marges en
action mais allez-y est ce que est ce
qu'il y a t-il un espace après vous pour
une négociation quelconque mais avec qui
des gossip ben je vois pas que le
gouvernement fédéral puisse céder
maintenant même si elle a envie de lever
les l'obligation vaccinale pour les
camionneurs je pense que là il peut plus
parler de sortie et peut-être que ce
monsieur donne aux états unis disait bob
et nous on a décidé que c'était
nécessaire et on l'élève ça pourrait
donner à monsieur trudeau de prétexte
pour faire la même chose mais tant qu'il
n'y a pas quelque chose comme ça il peut
pas céder devant
dépression le kiki qui sont presque une
forme de terrorisme joseph a pas de
négociation possible dans votre esprit
non non c'est pas c'est parce que
l'obligation maximum les camionneurs
c'est un prétexte là je pense que c'est
amplement documenté qu'on a à faire pour
ce qui est du noyau dur des
organisateurs à des gens d'extrême
droite et des complotistes à d'être au
pied et financé aussi pour les mêmes
raisons mais là c'est très très
généreusement ses de la scission là
c'est ça qu'on voit en ce moment donc il
ya pas de négociations avec ces gens là
le ver dans la pomme et je pense il
toronto star qui leur a porté mardi
c'est que le chef de police d'ottawa
il y aurait des responsables fédéraux
qui lui aurait demandé avant parce que
les anglais les attaques les ronettes
sur les médias sociaux qui voulaient
occuper à talloires il l'occupé notables
et élus ont demandé des vergers un
périmètre de sécurité pour protéger
c'est du classique donc au moins
empêcher les camions de s'installer il
ne l'a pas fait le chef de police
d'ottawa c'est très très grave
comme c'est une erreur pour laquelle on
paye au canada depuis ce temps elle mais
le mal est fait maintenant que faire bon
moi je suis pas experte en sécurité mais
je vais vous dire une chose avant
d'appeler l'armée ira sûrement à mettre
ces gens à leur sous arrestation
ces gens le brise la loi ces gens alors
on commettent des méfaits et on a des
forces policières au canada on a des
escouade antiémeute formés pour ça
qu'ils pourraient très bien rentrés et
les arrêter tout simplement et s'il ya
de la violence ce sera de la violence
qui viendra deux des protestataires ça
viendra potes de la police et même pas
besoin de faire remorquer les camions
après sa très franchement les clément et
d'audace ils vont pouvoir partir avec
donc il ya des choses à faire ça ne peux
plus je sais trudeau a dit aujourd'hui
ça ne peut plus continuer la phrase
suivante il a prononcé ces je vais
continuer à consulter et discuter avec
nonce un peu plus et c'est n'est plus
tolérable et où c'est la police ou c'est
l'art d'aimer comme le dit michel c'est
sûr que ça va mal c'est terminé le
problème c'est que le chef de police
d'ottawa en ce moment lui sa stratégie
on peut appeler ça comme ça c'est
d'essayer de négocier le retrait des
camions un camion à la fois la région
plongé par quatre
et ces gens là ces vaccinations qui les
intéresse c'est pas les mesures
salutaires c'est de déstabiliser la
démocratie canadienne c'est clair alors
il n'y a pas de négociation possible
pour quelque chose est-ce que
parallèlement sa pole et michel lefait
qu'une sortie d'un député comme live
band qui dit moi je trouve que mon
gouvernement mon premier ministre on
cherche en fait à trop divisés à jouer
sur la vaccination comme une arme comme
si c'était une arme politique
est ce que ça ne le met pas en position
de faiblesse monsieur trudeau pour gérer
toute cette histoire folle
oui le säntis de jouer les bandes me
sidère parce que c'est une élève vedette
de la classe de 2015 c'était un une
étoile montante du caucus libéral
et très fidèle et très partisan
il lui est en lui est arrivé de
m'envoyer des flèches lorsque j'écrivais
des lignes qui déposait au gouvernement
c'est comme si guy chevrette était
s'était érigé en rebelle contre
d'honneur landry dont mais ça vous dit
quoi sachant qu est ce que ça vous
qu'est-ce que ça ça m us ou dans quelle
position il
doit se sentir pour poignarder dans le
dos
pour moi c'est l'expression d'un ras le
bol
très poussé de la part de mr hyde band
ras-le-bol qui est très partagée dans
l'équipe libérale à ottawa qui ont le
sentiment que
s'il ne provoque pas une crise ils ne
sont pas écoutés sont pas vus par
l'entourage du premier ministre et ce
n'est pas le seul exemple qu'on a vu
cette semaine d'un député qui provoque
une crise au lieu de
corse qui en a assez de cet art ignorer
michel il y en a si je pense devoir que
son premier ministre au grade de régler
le problème
je pense que si il n'y avait pas eu
aussi ça s'était terminé très vite à
tahoua monsieur agba on aurait pas eu
tous ses états d'âme là et je dois dire
que je l'ait pas entendu pendant la
campagne électorale quand monsieur
trudeau a commencé carrément à faire de
la vaccination un objet de polarisation
et je pense que monsieur l'add on est
très content d'avoir gagné l'élection
grâce à sa quille aimerait pas
aujourd'hui se ramasser dans
l'opposition alors je trouve ça un peu
un peu cheap quand le gouvernement est
vraiment dans la mouise
jusqu'aux oreilles
d'arriver comme ça alors que ça fait des
mois que monsieur trudeau est accusée
d'utiliser les recettes
s'affaiblit monsieur trudeau bien
entendu un vis-à-vis les ja je parle pas
du noyau dur le josem et vis-à-vis tous
ces gens qui disent j'avais exagérons
geron corp avait exagéré pour la
vaccination des caméras etc donc ça
l'affaiblît monsieur trudeau là je sais
pas mais tu t'en fous furieux
lightbourne non mais tout à fait et et
d'ailleurs il ya une certaine
malhonnêteté intellectuelle chez
monsieur l'ipad parce que bon il accuse
enfin trudeau ou d'avoir utilisé la
vaccination comme objet de polarisation
mais les la vaccination c'est l'outil
principal que nous avons contre la
commune donc est ce que c'est c'est eh
de la politisation ou est ce que c'est
un geste responsable
pourquoi ne dit il pas non plus que les
conservateurs utilisent ex-policier
aussi la vaccination à s'étant opposé à
la vague hier obligatoire dans certains
domaines d'activité donc est ce que
monsieur l'album et cette souris sont
comptés dans la région de québec où
justement cette mouvance la monte et on
le voit au provincial avec parti d'eric
du ms qui se sent menacée dans son comté
aussi et là ils essaient de conforter
espèce de discours aussi de victimes la
peopoliser ont lâché chez ces gens là je
le sais pas mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord c'est vraiment s'écrie c'est
une gifle en plein visage de son chef il
nous reste cinq minutes je voudrais
parler je devrais changer de capitale
pour je vous faire entendre des extraits
aujourd'hui je le goût qui était furieux
il développé on est on est dans le même
sujet monsieur legault reproche à
l'opposition de jouer sur
là dessus en disant au lieu de condamner
ou et tout le monde condamne la halle et
la violence pour lieu au lieu d'arrêter
la phrase de vous ajouter que le
gouvernement répète plus clair c'est
parce qu'il n'a pas été clair que ça
crée la division la société que dans
quelques donc on écoute ce pont fait
le gouvernement par exemple de son côté
doit prendre acte qu'une certaine
polarisation à ce moment qu'il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui se posent des
questions et d'être encore plus
transparent je n'ai pas de recette
miracle ce que je sais c'est qu'il faut
prendre soin de nos démocraties pour
prendre soin de notre débat public faut
prendre soin de la cohésion sociale
parce que des déclarations comme celle
là puis surtout ce qu'elle reflète comme
et obtention c'est inquiétant une crème
qu'on doit prendre très au sérieux on
l'a vu ailleurs dans le monde ce genre
de menaces ne peut déraper rapidement le
parti libéral parti québécois sont
désespérés c'est totalement
irresponsable de venir cautionner des
gens qui menacent de prendre les armes
contre les consignes sanitaires entre un
lion un peu raison ça à foot du
gouvernement côté là c'est un tout bon
sain pour prendre toutes les mesures
avec les policiers pour protéger les
membres de notre gouvernement pour me
protéger mais
j'espérais avoir l'appui des oppositions
je n'avais tour de table rapide que ce
que vous avez vu là dedans d'abord moi
le l'histoire du manque de transparence
les gens ils sont fâchés contre les
mesures pas de manque de transparence
on sait parfaitement que il ya un
échéancier
c'est vrai que des fois il n'y a pas une
étude pour chaque confinement est ce que
dans les musées est ce que dans les
librairies à ce que le principe général
se dit mieux les contacte alors les
endroits où il ya beaucoup de contacts
mais on essaie d'en limiter l'accès
aux positions voulu faire des
tout à fait si l'opposition trouve que
les mesures vaccinale les mesures
sanitaires ont pas d'affaires là qu'il
dise ça y
est il pas assez transparents exactement
du charbon point paul je vous prêt je
suis désolé
oui et
je pense que je peux donner raison à
monsieur legault dans ce sens là il a
été très transparent il était présent
sur tous les tribunes depuis deux ans et
est aussi essayer de tirer profit
politiquement comme parti d'opposition
d'une insurrection c'est une opération
très délicate et je déconseillerais à
tout parti d'opposition n'importe où
dans le vert j'osais je reviens ce que
j'étais assez comme pour monsieur x et
c'est comme si l'opposition
voulait prendre un peu de capital
7 dans ce mouvement là qui grandit de
dire il ya trop de mesures center en
même temps sans dire directement que
l'on veut tout dire bref soyez plus que
les jmj
très dangereux auquel se sont livrés des
partis d'opposition aujourd'hui
cotée sur six ont carrément fait l
amalgame entre ces menaces il a qui
circulent la part des organisateurs qui
rapporte que d'autres personnes pensent
rappeur des tutelles va ton désespéré
par les mesures sanitaires la côte et ce
quand même assez grave et le manque de
transparence de monsieur legault se
poser dans la gestion de la pandémie
tout excuser moi la sondeuse qu'elles
sont complètement séparés et si j'étais
sujet tqs et le parti québécois et le
parti libéral je prête très attention là
dessus il ya une crise en ce moment et
une foule dans la société en ce moment
et qui sont des idées vraiment des
jeunes qui vont peut-être être prêt à
aller très loin dans ce qu'ils font si
paul table d alimenter le d'aucune
manière pour des raisons partie josep
allez michel merci beaucoup bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit